you were in mr rogers neighborhood
yeah
i mean do you remember it at all do you
remember fred rogers
you know what's so sad is that i
remember everything and i i'm
the fact that we didn't have cell phones
back then and i didn't bring a camera
is it it was it just breaks my heart
because
it was incredible to be
on that set so what was it like that you
remember
being on set
of mr rogers neighborhood
well
first of all mr rogers
what'd i say
he's exactly the way
you see him
i mean just sweet kind quiet soft-spoken
and i thought he was a little crazy at
first because i would hear him behind
the castle king friday's castle like
talking to himself
what was he saying but i didn't realize
he was just running the lines with his
puppets oh right right right
how old are you
i was in college
wait a minute you're on mr rogers and
you're in college
yes they needed some trumpeteers
and um so me and two of my classmates
volunteered
and we got to do it
and you wow so you have a vivid memory i
thought i was like wow i can't believe
she remembers all this she was a young
kid you were not a kid no no i was
i was 18 years old and i thought mr
rogers was crazy
like i literally i'm like he's talking
to himself a lot back there
did he really talk so slowly and sweetly
and calmly yes
yeah it it it was incredible yeah to be
on that set
yeah and how many things had you done by
18 years old before you went to carnegie
mellon were you already doing
playstation
equity card
really
and is mom still trying to dissuade you
at this moment in time no she takes all
the credit
now she takes all the credit i mean back
then when you were 18 is she like still
trying to say no as soon as i i got into
carnegie mellon
and she knew that that was a very
because you know it's pittsburgh it's
one of pittsburgh's most prestigious
college big college
so
when i got into carnegie mellon then she
realized like oh well first she was like
oh american school is so easy
because
because she didn't think that you could
get a degree
in acting like
i thought you were gonna say because my
daughter got in
yeah well she got in for acting